what's up this is tracks and we're gonna
be breaking down some of my favorite
change from on the rocks little yachty
so when it comes to making those 3d
pieces that 3d Bart that has more pop
than even the original Gucci Mane piece
right when Gucci man did his piece it
was early in the game he was a
groundbreaker on it good to me he did a
Bart Simpson piece a long time ago and I
recreated it you know I'm saying pay
homage to Gucci but of course as time
goes on whether it's cars or fashion
things evolve now when yachty made this
piece he's got a boat on the back which
is one of his name sakes and the model
maker gave it some fluff some pop he
went with a little bit of a gallery back
which means that it's not a solid back
you could see inside the piece not a bad
thing when you want to clean it when you
want to get that shine to pop even more
little pump a little pump did not slack
on any of his jewelry monster fully ice
pieces he loves white gold he's got the
rose gold white gold look of course big
diamonds in the eyes fully ice dreads
you know that's the look he loves and
ice box did a good job for him
he spent millions of dollars on this
piece but the one that's the flyest out
of all of them he's got multicolored
chains he's got everything but the drug
addict piece done by Ellie ante with the
specialized chain and the different
pills the Superman pill all sorts of
pills are being gobbled up over there
he's not slacking he wants to spend his
millions on his jewelry he's shown the
world what he's all about how he rolls
and he is killing it with this one got
to safety lock so we'll never pop on him
so you click the first lock in see it
doesn't move and then that's the safety
lock two safety locks on that chain of
course is a must when you're spending
almost half a million dollars on a chain
the last thing you want to do when
you're partying and everything you're
doing is look down and say oops I lost
my chain Ellie on Tay definitely did
that super safety lock that's very
popular in the modern jewelry business
that's one of the evolutions no more
little lobsters you got to have that
super safety lock that means if the
chain is gone you're gone with it huevo
this piece right here came from inspired
by the prayers been a cool game quavo
got another fruity colored piece to
Crash Bandicoot with a custom chain all
right a lot of pop a lot of different
color diamonds green diamonds are the
rarest color of diamonds that you could
put in one of these pieces they're
extremely rare now these are irradiated
green but even when diamonds are
irradiated for that color only one out
of a hundred turns green so you got to
do hundreds and hundreds of carats until
you get a couple of carats of green
diamonds that's why you don't see it in
a lot of pieces but he's got it and he
did not slack on that one off set off
set has the traphouse piece another
complicated interesting revolutionary
piece that set monstrous amounts of
friends went viral customized diamond
chain on that now of course you got the
Trap House with the characters inside
with the hinge dropping open all right
you got a stove in there a rose ghost
over rose nope I got a money back
this was 250 a quarter these are all
complexities of the jewelry business
it's not just about fully ice it's not
just about diamonds and gold it's also
about craftsmanship 3-dimensional that
means they had to assemble the walls
assemble the roof set up the inside put
it all together polish it make sure the
inside is clean it's harder to do than
it looks
okay gucci mane gucci mane is a diamond
jewelry legend he did all the cartoon
pieces he set all those trends but now
he graduated to something clean and
classy but the price tag just went up
right the big pointers are ten times
more rare every time you go a diamond
size up okay this bracelet right here is
like a another tennis bracelet rose gold
with Jones hanging on it I got made but
then I went back and got the change made
with it you're looking at another like
quarter-million dollar so every time you
go diamond sized up the diamonds become
ten times more rare and ten times the
price you could get the smaller diamonds
for a thousand dollars a carat the
diamond cheese using there are no less
than six to fourteen thousand dollars a
carat per stone so you do the math count
the stones
the numbers and you're gonna see
millions of dollars spent on elite
diamond pieces waka flocka flame the
foghorn leghorn piece is got its extra
size heavy duty the red diamonds really
pop that's what really catches my eye on
those piece those red diamonds are not
cheap he got him all matching his
jeweller didn't cut any corners on that
red diamonds are very very rare they're
hard to get that color out of them I
wanted to stand up you know I'm saying
it was big as hell so if it's you know
everything's like up here now when it
comes to his revolver piece it's got
that spinning barrel function
you know the jeweler had to make that
happen for him because you want your gun
to have that functionality of it so it
doesn't look like just a prop or some
past model of a piece right so he had
that done that all adds complexity that
all adds depth and labor to the piece
that you're making that's what he's
representing over there that's an elite
piece of jewelry as well not a kid's toy
that is just a clump of gold unwell
unwell has a du Vinci masterpiece going
on over here right you have Jesus versus
the devil a beautiful scene with
chocolate diamonds white diamonds red
diamonds orange diamonds but the most
beautiful thing about this piece is the
hand-painted enamel that's not what you
see on a lot of other pieces they're
missing that specific touch so when
you're doing hand-painted enamel an
artist has to by hand through the hair
do the colors do that background scene
that you're seeing there and then harden
it in an oven to cook the paint so it
turns into almost like a rock coating
it's not the most valuable thing when it
comes to materials but when it comes to
quality to craftsmanship that's the
touch you want on your elite piece to
set you aside from everybody else and
that's what happened here Tyger Tyger
did something elite with this diamond
chain he used one of the greatest brands
on the planet goyard the luxury fashion
brand he took their logo and he
customized it to make an elite diamond
chain link okay not easy to do he had to
be clever to direct his jeweler to be
able to use that link to make it
functional that takes craftsmanship to
he came up with a beautiful idea who
would have known that that type of logo
from a luxury fashion brand could be
beated through to make beautiful diamond
chain
he's a trendsetter with that that was an
elite jewelry idea and then he's got the
monster Pharaoh head fully iced classic
he likes his jewelry done correctly a
touch on the side something on the back
a unique bail that's what the jewelry
business is that's the trend big pointer
change the time when I came up with it I
was like really into learning about
Africa and learning about Egyptian
culture and all that stuff like that so
I was just kind of fascinated by you got
to have a little class when you're
manufacturing your jewelry he took it a
step above a lot of other rappers post
Malone so post Malone has a crazy unique
jewelry set he's got the black diamond
God's team Dallas Cowboys star with the
baguettes around it all right it's God's
team as he says it's the America's best
football team he's obviously a fan he
got the pendant made then he's got the
dmitri head also with black diamond so
he's got that matching look at black
enamel in the eyes it's a beautiful
combo but it doesn't stop there he was
gifted from his studio where he records
that with their logo electric field two
pendants for him to mix and match his
everyday pieces it's good business he's
got a good business relationship they
make money he makes money of course they
should give them some jewelry okay
now the most unique piece that he has
which isn't super unique because he
copied it off of Jesse from the
neighborhood as he says but this is the
Chanel candy necklace now it's not made
out of candy and he didn't get it for
Halloween but it has that Halloween
nostalgia when you got it as a kid you
got that candy necklace you wore
whatever your first necklace that it was
he decided to get that Chanel piece it's
not golden diamonds it's not the most
precious materials but it's not all
about that when you're an artist it's
about the look it's about the feeling
that you want to convey with your
jewelry he does that his way like he
does everything else dj khaled dj khaled
has been giving the world major keys for
a long time he's got some in return from
none other than Greek he's got his name
his son's name yellow gold yellow
white gold white diamonds for Assad each
key leads to the next key you know I got
the keys
he says everything his first son I
believe him right he's got a beautiful
jewelry collection I'm sure he's gonna
pass it on to his son he's got a sacred
Allah pendant means most high in Arabic
it's just the Arabic word for God it was
originally an ancient word meaning Most
High obviously he's a spiritual man he
wants to live for his family he wants to
do the right thing he wants to share his
blessings he wants to share the major
keys of life and he's doing that in a
spiritual sense of course he's got his
big boy but get pieces from pristine the
bracelet the chain to match the
protective elite that's the trend big
boy pieces big boy but get diamonds got
the high quality vs it's not playing
around he wanted to fully ice that to
make it happen he did it
an elite chopper as the jeweler I love
the bicycle chain link
it's got the big diamonds in the link
fully iced all around fully functional I
wouldn't want to throw it on my BMX bike
and start taking it for a spin
but he says it's fully functional I'll
take him at his word you might want to
just enjoy wearing it around your neck
as that choker and a bracelet piece
matches a watch that's something I wish
I had in my shop he might even be able
to sell that to me when rappers make it
to the elite of the hip-hop game their
jewelry collection spells out who they
are it could be a story where they're
from it could be a story of their
namesake it could be a story who they're
doing business with who their friends
are it could be millions of dollars it
could be big pointers it could be candy
the choice is theirs these elite rappers
made it to the top of the game and now
the jeweler works for them
[Music]